this video is brought to you by
thinkific one of the fastest and most
impactful ways to get your knowledge out
into the world make more money and make
a bigger impact is to take that
knowledge that's lying dormant in your
brain and turn it into a high impact
high income online course here at think
media we are a team of successful course
creators generating multiple seven
figures in online courses and helping
people just like you create a successful
online business i get it it can be so
overwhelming when it comes to starting
your online course but in this free
tutorial i'm going to take you step by
step on how to get started and get your
course out to the world in this free
tutorial i'm walking you through how to
create your course content
how to film and edit your videos to make
it fast and easy where you should be
hosting your online course so you and
your students get the best experience
and how to market your online course so
grab a notebook grab your pen and let's
jump into this episode of the youtube
made simple show
[Music]
alrighty let's jump into tip number one
to get you started on your online course
we want to start with picking your
content and topic ideas i have a couple
questions for you because this is where
people start and get overwhelmed at the
very beginning what should you even make
your course about and this is the
opportunity for you to get a blank piece
of paper out a pencil and we're just
gonna start writing things on it so
here's some questions for you what
skills and talents and life experience
do you have
and what audience needs what you have
those are two key things it's what you
want to teach but it's also what
audience is there to view it write out
some things maybe
you are a master gardener you've been
growing a garden for the last 20 years
and you want to package that knowledge
and help beginners newbies on their
journey to understanding how to start a
successful garden now what would you
teach in that what type of topics would
you want to talk about that if you go
more the scientific route and you want
to do more into the soil and those types
of things or do you want to do something
like how to make it in a kit there's so
many ways you can go about this but this
is the opportunity for you to just grab
the piece of paper and just start
writing just start to expand on some
topics i think about one of the courses
that i want to create it's all about
homeschooling i'm a homeschooling mom
and so i want to teach other homeschool
moms and in this course content tip i
want you to think about the life
experience that you have the skills that
you have and also identifying the
audience that you want to reach with
this course if you try and reach
everyone you will end up reaching no one
so you have to be clear is it someone
that's a beginner are they intermediate
are they in a life transition write
about this person so that you can start
to identify who your course is for now
you may be thinking yeah but i'm not an
expert at anything maybe if you're like
me where you kind of are a jack of all
trades right well you don't actually
need to be an expert i know it sounds
crazy but you don't have to be an expert
to create a course all you're doing is
packaging your knowledge in a
step-by-step sequence to help someone on
a journey you're going to help them get
from point a to point z so if you've
experienced it if you've got the
receipts to prove it then you can teach
it so you don't have to be an expert you
can be a guide you could be a leader you
could be a friend that's just a little
bit more on the journey than someone
else so let's debunk the idea that you
have to be an expert in order to create
an online course now the next step that
we're gonna go to is we're actually
going to go out and do some market
research it's time to start
investigating now this is my warning
this is not a time for you to compare
yourself to someone else all we're going
to do right now is just investigate what
are other course creators doing on this
topic how much are they charging how
many students are enrolled in their
courses we want to start investigating
what is out there in the market are
people actually even interested in what
you want to produce this is a critical
time before we even start recording
before we even go through mapping out
these modules we want to really
investigate are people interested in
what you are about to sell now i
recommend going and searching for two to
five other course creators to see what
is the competition offering a lot of
times in course creation people will
give you kind of an outline of what they
would be teaching in their content go in
and see what can you actually fill the
gap with what skills do you have life
experience that you have that could help
you stand out from the competition now
your job is to figure out will someone
actually pay for the content that you
are producing and a great way to figure
this out is to actually start to
pre-sell your course before you create
it now here's how you do this if you are
building an email list if you are
currently a content creator if you're a
podcaster or you already have an
audience of some size you can actually
pre-sell the course that you want to
create you can create a very simple
landing page with thinkific and they can
help you actually pre-sell your course
before it's created now here's what's
great about this you can do a limited
time run you can do a discount you can
offer only a certain amount of people
inside of your course during that
pre-sale and all they're doing is they
are getting on the wait list for the
release of your course this will help
you actually understand
what people need and what they want this
gives you an opportunity to
survey them and see where their
struggles are and be able to create
exactly what they need for the course
that you want to create now if you want
more details about how to pre-sell your
course i will link down in the
description below an amazing blog post
that thinkific dig that walks you step
by step through the process of a
pre-sale now tip number three is to
create your outcomes for success we are
not to actually creating the course yet
we actually want to identify what does
winning look like for your students this
is huge and where a lot of course
graders go wrong they just start
creating things but they don't actually
figure out what does winning look like
here's the thing people
buy solutions so you've got to identify
what are the one to three solutions that
your course is going to solve a great
way to identify this is to write this
sentence out by the end of this course
you will fill in the blank what are they
achieving what is the outcome that
you're going to promise them
as someone who is going to be a part of
this course it is so critical that you
can identify what winning looks like for
them so that you can win as a course
creator the next step in the process is
to outline your course this is my
favorite part because we're gonna take
those three outcomes that you identified
we're gonna put them on some sticky
notes and we're gonna go to town here's
what you're gonna do you're going to
identify the steps in the process that
it takes to get to that outcome so if
the outcome is as a homeschooler like i
want to create to understand the type of
homeschool you want to have right to
identify
how to have a peaceful homeschool that's
what the outcome i want them to have now
the steps to actually do that are about
figuring out the rhythms and the
schedule for your students for your kids
so that would be the steps i would walk
through the different steps of how to
actually make that possible so what
steps do your students need in order to
achieve those outcomes for the goals
that you have identified now if you want
to go deeper into this process if you're
getting stuck or you just want to
actually have an outline or a template
to help you go through the outlining of
your course process thinkific has a
phenomenal download that i'll link down
below and a blog post to help you walk
through the steps of actually outlining
a successful course now that you know
the outcomes and you have a general
outline to your course it's time to
structure these into modules you're
going to start to group similar themes
and tips and ideas into consumable
modules these are the actual segments of
your course and inside of those you're
going to have different videos that will
help them progress through the course so
maybe your first module is a big idea
and you want to break that into three
different videos we're gonna just start
to put those sticky notes in place to be
able to make this outline into a
consumable structure a great way to
achieve this is to storyboard your
course what does the journey look like
from start to finish from a to z when it
comes to the online course that you're
creating i've linked down below a
resource from thinkific to walk you
through how to storyboard with their
download now i know that you want to
over deliver on the course content that
you're creating but did you know that
there is a science behind how long your
videos should be and how to
progressively take students through your
online course well i'm going to link
below a great resource that i read
through on the thinkific blog that
walked me through even a deeper
knowledge of how i should be structuring
my course all right we're getting closer
and closer to your course being done and
next is actually determining how do you
want to deliver your course what are the
different learning styles you want to
incorporate are you going to be doing
video lessons slideshows or maybe you're
recording yourself talking on stage or
maybe you want to do a sit down video
just like this are you wanting to do
audio downloads do you want to have
opportunities for your students to
download maybe ongoing learning and
training or to be able to separate the
video and the audio content this is a
great way if you have a course where
people can learn on the go is to have
the option for audio downloads and
speaking of downloads everyone loves a
good action guide template or a
checklist so make sure you are including
that inside of your course and lastly
you want to consider what is the
community aspect of your course one
thing i love about the thinkific
platform is they have so many ways for
you to actually design a community
within your course there are membership
opportunities and ways that you can have
your students connecting with each other
holding each other accountable or asking
for feedback on the things that they are
creating now if you don't want to do any
type of community that is okay but you
want to just make sure that you're
thinking about what does this look like
for people who are signing up and
finally you want to decide the length of
your course now here's the thing the
longer the course doesn't mean the
better the course you can create a
phenomenal short course that can get
massive value for your audience it's
about the outcomes not about the length
of time a study was actually done by
over 3 000 course creators on thinkific
and it was determined that the length of
the course was not in relation to the
revenue generated from the course this
is great if you are short on time and
you don't actually want your course to
be 10 hours long maybe you want a course
that's only two hours long or three
hours long but it's okay if you have
enough content to fill 10 hours as long
as the outcome is achieved you want to
be mindful though about who your course
is for if is it for busy moms who only
have a few short minutes to be taking in
the knowledge that you're providing
maybe you're you're helping busy
entrepreneurs or maybe you're helping
new students learn a skill knowing who
your audience is and who your course is
for will help you determine the length
of time for the course that you're
creating for them i love this quote from
chalene johnson she says be brief be
bright be fun and be done one thing that
people over the last decade have come to
a consensus on is that they don't want
fluff they want the meat and potatoes of
your course so give them what they want
now it's okay if you want to add in a
story or two or help to illustrate
pieces of your course but hear me friend
you want to please your customer and
your customer is pleased when they can
get to their outcome the fastest way
possible and now we get to the fun part
of recording and editing your online
course now there's a couple ways you can
go about this if you decide to do just a
voiceover and a slideshow you can use
different software like google slides
you can use powerpoint canva easy simple
ways that you can be creating slides and
then just recording over them you can do
this on a computer if you have quicktime
or you can use a simple software like
stream yard if you want to still have
your face on screen and have a little
bit more of a dynamic flow to your
content now if you are going to be
recording a course just like this a
talking head course and you're new to
online creation of videos we have so
many resources for you starting with how
to film edit and upload with your phone
all the way to using a fancy camera and
lighting just like this so i'll make
sure to link all of those resources down
in the description for you and here is a
pro tip you want to make sure that every
time you are recording a video and you
are putting it on your computer that you
are labeling that file and that you are
keeping yourself organized along this
entire journey please do not have your
videos as video 1 or video 1-1
actually label the videos to the title
of that video and it will help you
throughout the process of recording
editing and uploading your video on your
course platform well now that you have
your videos ready to go it is time to
upload them to your course platform and
like i said this video is brought to you
in partnership with thinkific which is a
phenomenal online course platform
thinkific is an online course platform
built to help you create sell and
deliver your online course under your
own brand over 50 000 course creators
from 90 different countries are building
their online education businesses using
thinkific think of it gives you the
tools to build and customize a premium
learning experience that your students
will love
you can process payments and automate an
enrollment into your course without any
hassle and they can help you easily
create a branded course website so you
can confidently launch your online
course entrepreneurs small business
owners and organizations of many
different sizes use thinkific and offer
freed and paid online courses and
memberships in tons of industries they
also have an app store to help you
customize your course business even
further from celebrating your students
milestones with personal animations to
showcasing real-time course purchases
the thinkific app store helps you bring
your teaching vision to life if you are
interested in getting started with
thinkific i will leave all of the
information for the best pricing
possible for you in the description box
below
now that we have your course uploaded to
your course hosting site it is time to
create your sales page now this is
different than a web page because this
sales page has one purpose and one
purpose only and that is to move your
future students from viewing to buying
thinkific makes it so easy for you to
create this sales page where you have
different ways that you can show your
students what is inside and expected in
the course now winning sales pages that
will convert future students to current
students have a few elements that are
critical on the page the first element
is a compelling headline you want to
make sure that you are actually
identifying what your course is about
and
the introduction of the problem because
again we're going to tell them about the
outcomes that this course will give them
on your sales page you want to make sure
you have highlights of the benefits and
the solutions that they are going to get
from your course you can do bullet
points of the different elements of the
offer and any bonuses that you are
deciding to package with this course
adding testimonials will help with
social proof and not just you saying
your course is great but other people
saying your course is great and don't
worry as you are growing this online
course you can get those testimonials
and add them later to this page then you
want to make sure you are including your
credibility a little bit about you and
your bio on that as well as faqs because
believe me people will have objections
so every single one of your faq should
be addressing one of those objections
and next of course the price and nice
and big is the buy button now on any
sales page you want to have a risk
reversal this could be a 7-day
money-back guarantee 15-day money-back
guarantee or a 30-day money-back
guarantee this is critical because you
want people to be able to get in your
course and know that there's no risk for
them in the purchase okay take a deep
breath i know that was a lot but we
still need to figure out how to market
your course i have a few tips for you
here and i want to know in the comment
section below are you starting an online
course and let me know what your course
is about all right in marketing your
course we already covered a little bit
about pre-selling you can get the link
down below if you'd like to go deeper
into understanding that but again
remember you can offer discounts you can
offer just a certain amount of people to
get access to it but you want to be
creating that wait list before the
course is created now it's time to
market your course and if you are on
youtube already you already have an
avenue to do this this is through video
creation this is through email sending
there are so many ways you can be
marketing your course online now like i
said if you are already creating youtube
videos you can create those videos and
then just give a call to action that
says if you want to go deeper in this
type of content i have an online course
and you can get that link down in the
description now what i love so much
about using youtube as the marketing
platform is that youtube will work for
you while you snooze meaning that once
you create that video that leads to your
online course if you've done your job
right meaning that you've created a
video that people are interested in that
people are searching for and that people
are finding solutions to their problems
for then you can actually take people
off of youtube and send them right over
to your sales page now depending on the
price of your course i recommend that
you don't actually just sell right on
youtube you want to offer something free
before that so a couple ways that you
can market this is if your course is
under say a thousand dollars you can
offer a free download and then you can
offer them the course now if your course
is over a thousand dollars i recommend
actually doing a webinar you want to
give free value up front before someone
makes that purchase i'll link down below
different resources if you want to learn
how to create a great webinar that can
help you convert your course and now you
are ready to get started i hope that
this free tutorial has helped you on
your course creating journey and if you
decide to join thinkific as your course
hosting platform you'll get access to
their free youtube resource guide this
guide is going to help you walk through
the first steps you should take to
monetize your video content through your
online course and you'll learn how to
uncover the value proposition and map
out your content for your course to help
lead to sales thank you so much for
watching this video and if you'd like to
check out another video in the youtube
made simple series you can click or tap
the screen right now and if you have
more questions about how to get started
on that email list then click or tap the
screen right now for that next video
thanks for watching
you